jocelyn né en 1978 dans une petite ville
de bretagne
son enfance fut tout à fait douce est
tranquille
jocelyn glisse doucement vers l'âge
adulte en parallèle de ses études il
travaille souvent avec nico son pote
d'enfance et photographe automobile avec
lui ils se déplacent régulièrement dans
toute l'europe à bord des bolides les
plus luxueux c'est peut être là que naît
son goût du voyage alors qu'il rend
visite à sa famille son passé le
rattrape en sortant de soirée il tombe
sur un mec jaloux qui cherche à se
venger à propos d'une vieille histoire
de coeur au premier coup à la tempe
joselin s'effondre en une fraction de
seconde pour un motif futile son destin
basculer
résultat comme à profond jocelyn est en
réanimation entre la vie et la mort il
n'est pas opérable trachéotomisés sous
assistance respiratoire branché de
partout
le corps constellé de capteurs le
tableau est horrible pour ses proches
mais du point de vue de choses là c'est
pire
la conscience piégé dans ce corps
paralysé impossible de communiquer
impossible de savoir
impossible de comprendre finalement
jocelyn sort du coma au bout de 21 jours
presque comme par mira
bonsoir à tous depuis 15 ans pas et
voilà devant vous avec fauteuils et
aussi avec quelques problèmes
d'élocution qui vont certainement vous
demandez un peu plus d'attention pour
bien de comprendre mes cheveux nuit sur
cette scène malgré tout je suis là
pouvoir coter en histoire avec cette
histoire
j'aurais pu parler longuement du comment
la rééducation ou de la dépression
je veux plus te les avoirs des
rapidement m'intéresser davantage
est ce qu'il s'est passé après déjà dans
mon cas les trois semaines de coma ont
été bien intense apparemment je vais une
activité cérébrale plate
autant c'était le bordel dans le disque
dur une petite anecdote pour vous situer
l'ambiance je suis allongé sûrement à
l'hôpital mon lit doit rouler car je
vois le plafond des filets la jal ferait
un infirmier que j'avais jamais vu avant
il claque devant ajuste aussi une les
yeux mais rien je ne n'arrive pas à
bouger ni d'oeil rien alors il secoue la
tête
puis quelqu'un referma couvert petit
moment là je me rends compte
il ne croit mort on à la morgue ils vont
ranger dans un tiroir
alors moi je criais et s'en sortir juive
en rien ne sort rien ne bouge
je vous tue d'un coup le plafond de
l'iss et la lumière jaillit c'est bon
change de sortie
j'ai compris par la suite que je pensais
juste un scanner avec les films on a une
fausse image du commun on voit les gens
qui sont en sorte comme s'ils se
réveiller d'un long sommeil et ça repart
tranquille mais en vrai c'est bien plus
compliqué pour vous donner une image
je veux retrouver avec leur conscience
d'un adulte coincé dans le corps d'un
nourrisson mais sans la vitalité
imaginez vous
il volait tout réapprendre et avec ce
corps qui marche mal mais vraiment tout
rien que boire un verre d'eau tout seul
donne un double exploit fille sd pour
communiquer aussi au début rien sortais
je devais pointé du doigt analphabètes
géant pour avoir les conversations alors
tenir une discussion tout d'un coup
galère puis s'est retrouvé comment faire
bouger ses muscles les uns après les
autres et tout ça lentement patiemment
jour après jour semaine après semaine
mois après mois on appelle ça la
réducation la mienne a pris deux ans en
centre spécialisé
j'ai dû me confronter à ce nouveau corps
comprendre que ma situation vin était
pas temporaire et me familiariser avec
ce nouveau compagnon
puis un jour la prise en charge s'arrête
et c'est le grand retour dans le monde
des valides en sortie de centre j'étais
abattu je me sentais détruits je me suis
souvent posé la question mais pourquoi
moi suivi de ce pas juste alors là c'est
bizarre parce que on est pris entre la
comparaison permanente avec sa vie
d'avant et soulagement de juste traite
encore là et ont fait du yo-yo en
permanence entre à vis de vous vous
doutez bien que pendant longtemps quand
on parlait de bonheur on sait que ça
n'était plus pour moi pensaient que
c'était réservé aux hôtes
on parle pas être heureux un jour mais
je voulais ça de loin
loin très loin je n'y croyais plus
vraiment en fait
et voilà ces quelques anecdotes
pour résumer en quelques minutes des
années dures à traverser et me
permettent d'arriver à ce qui compte au
final ce qui fait que je suis là
aujourd'hui à vous parler
malgré cette allocution malgré ce
fauteuil tout le reste cette question
c'est que fait-on après la catastrophe
comment redonner du sens à sa vie après
un choc d'une telle ampleur
dans mon cas ça s'appelle sévère
traumatisme crânien ayant entraîné
d'incapacité physique permanente de 80%
pour doute ça sera autre chose
la liste est malheureusement trop
longues et donc comment redonner du sens
à sa vie
pour ma part ça a démarré avec la
proposition d'un de mes frères partons
en voyage loin longtemps new york fut le
grand ouest américain pendant deux mois
j'ai la boule au ventre mais je pars
c'était la première fois que je quittais
l'europe ce voyage est une claque une
vraie bouffée d'oxygène
malgré les nombreux problèmes rencontrés
sur place
cette aventure m'a permis de redécouvrir
le sens du mot bonheur ça va montrer
comment en fauteuil je voulais
entreprendre construire découvrir des
choses réaliser des projets bref que la
vie continuait et quand j'ai pris
conscience de cette planète qui ouvrait
ses bras ma situation
ouais j'suis tour gourmand j'en veux
toujours plus j'ai forcément lutte
continue alors forcément en voyage il ya
des imprévus comme cette fois au
rajasthan ou là c'est carrément un
cheval qui m'a percuté et qui avait filé
net on faisait avec son cerveau et c'est
pas facilement du bonhomme et mais quand
ça arrive on se débrouille bref je
pourrais pourtant vous dire que le
voyage marveaux et des remontées la
vente va redonner confiance en moi dans
plusieurs endroits
j'ai même pu relativiser mon malheur se
replacer un peu se dire qu'au final on
fait partie des chanceux bref le voyage
a été un véritable bouée de sauvetage et
un ascenseur pour le bien-être il m'a
surtout permis de positiver et c'est
comme ça je suis devenu un globaux leur
vin way love roller et en plus il ya des
trucs que j'ai appris ou perfectionner
sur le temps
if you want expliqué rich oisillons ou
alors au lac et hal gill paul preston et
soit contenu à blaise espagnol ou bien
au liban
c est au salon pour guignery portugaise
ou alors salins cucchi la baisse elne à
cookshire l1 du lilas tout ça alors je
n'avais pas signé de montbeton le virus
m'a piqué dépit je pars je pars dès que
je peux et souvent seulement non je pars
et je veux voir plus loin là bas
alors c'est sûr partie en voyage en
fauteuil
c'est moins simple ça comporte de
nombreuses difficultés supplémentaires
et bizarrement la grande difficulté que
l'on comptera chaque fois elle n'a rien
avril handicap c'est juste le manque
d'informations spécifiques
un exemple pour les au corcovado
vous savez la statue du christ sur les
hauteurs de rio de janeiro qui va vous
prévenir qu après le funiculaire puis
l'ascenseur il reste encore un escalier
pour accéder au christ en l'occurrence
un escalier de 17 marches
oui oui 17 marches allez demander à ma
petite amie aux visiteurs qui m'ont
porté ce jour là bah ouais parmi eux
restés bloqués si près du but et c'est
vrai que pour beaucoup
parti en voyage c'est plus ou moins
simples quelques formalités c'est réglé
au pire on peut improviser sur place
pour moi pour nous tout se complique
il faut à chaque fois tout regarder son
côté accessibilité et justement ces
informations la cruciale et essentielle
sont peu ou pas disponible alors moi
j'ai voulu qu'elles existent d'abord
premier voyage ensuite j'ai ouvert ce a
d'autres qui sont fenouil ou pas
d'ailleurs et c'est devenu un site qui
donne des informations sur
l'accessibilité pour faciliter le voyage
des personnes à mobilité réduite
un guide mobile pour les gens qui le
sont moins et grasasa faire boule de
neige et faire naître d'autres
le brûleur lors de mon dernier séjour en
inde
j'ai eu une scène qui va faire réfléchir
dans un oui oui où je mangeais un couple
de personnes aveugles est entré et les
gens l'auront tous tendus naturellement
leur main pour les aider à ce qui est
jusqu'à table de libre
ça s'est fait simplement personne n'a
perdu tant personne semblé gênés où
personne n'a eu peur de manger froid et
ça me confirme l idée que si l'on est
beaucoup à faire juste un petit peu au
final ça pourra faire une différence
énorme émoi
par exemple les effets du film
intouchables je vous ai ressenti
il ya depuis plus de petits gestes plus
à sourire
moins de gêne à mon égard le genre de
chose qui allège un mal être
quand le monde on évolue tous les jours
des pas vraiment fait pour moi et quand
j'y pense j'ai beau m'être battue je
veux avoir réussi à sortir la tête de
l'eau
je ne vaincraient pas mon handicap je
resterai toujours bloqués devant une
marche mais ce qui me permet de franchir
cette foutue marche
vous appréciez vous parler c'est d'être
en paix avec lui on peut dire que j'ai
trouvé une thérapie je veux la partager
et faciliter ces choses pour ceux qui
ont aussi des problèmes de mobilité
je souhaite partager mes expériences de
globo leur ai montré que c'est possible
que malgré des difficultés malgré les
apparences une partie des barrières sont
parfois dans la tête
alors voilà c'est mon histoire une vie
comme tout à chacun mais bouleversée par
un drame qui a tout balayé puis le long
chemin de la résilience pour que ce
drame ne soit pas un coup d'arrêt mais
un renouveau et qu'au final je ressemble
même grandi mon déclic qui avance et la
reconstruction a été un voyage mais la
résilience est faite par le voyage alors
maintenant quand je connais un peu mieux
je crois je peux vous le dire
pendant longtemps j'ai sincèrement cru
ne plus jamais goûté au bonheur vend
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire que je me
suis trompé je suis fier et heureux
heureux de faire quelque chose qui
puisse rendre les autres heureux et pour
conclure j'espère deux choses 1 que mon
exemple qui zonaient à doute la volonté
de s'accrocher à trouver leur thérapie
et leur déclic et 2 que beaucoup valide
ou pas comment ce restaurant en inde se
sentiront assez concernés pour
contribuer aussi à rentrer sont le plus
accessible